what's up kids family it's your boy
meech here back with our debate show
sneaker swap where we argue a lot
okay i have my usual guys with me cj
toledano christian pierre
and jeff johnson what's going on fellas
you're good
man bro exciting exciting
we have a really interesting topic for
today guys it is
if you had a yeezy 350
would you trade it for a nike roast run
i know it's crazy it's crazy
but talk to me is this a prank show
what's the catch what's the catch cause
um
i'm not doing that i'm keeping the 350.
it's like
it's like trading the the the 2020 model
of a car
for the 2000 version you know what i'm
saying like it's it's in the same vein
and
clearly the 350s to me are the better
shoe they're the more sought after shoe
they're probably worth more than the
roches it doesn't make any sense
yeah um i'm not trading the 350s for the
real shrunk man
it almost sounds like deranged talking
about it to be honest
i'm not going to split in three fifties
like that the thrifties are low-key
still
some people's grills like maybe not me
personally but i like them a lot they're
grilled for a lot of people
it's almost like if you were to offer me
like 350 rush runs for
350 i'm still picking the 350s this
is the kanye effect what can i say
listen uh i'll play devil's advocate
here
um we wouldn't have the 350s if it
wasn't for the roshi runs
thank you cj um and honestly
and honestly if you took kanye's name
off those shoes
and you're a nike loyalist or if you're
a nike sneakerhead
you know i don't know i might pick i
might pick the swoosh over just you know
some prime knit so i mean i i know i
also don't like a lot of the color ways
the yeezy 350s so
uh and it to me it's just like the
ultimate height beast indicator
so i'm gonna ride with the roshi runs
here
wow wow you're rocking with the roaches
and listen i did a little bit of
research
we'll get to it i have to spread out my
ammo
but uh yeah i'm comfortable with this
i'm comfortable with this
cj i can't i can't say you're wrong if
it wasn't for the roshi
like there might not be a 350 because
like kanye said himself i feel it
but if i to be honest like i don't like
i don't know everybody talking about did
the roach did the easy replace
the roshi's right i literally the ultra
boost 1.0
are the shoe that replaced the roshi's
to be honest and
funny enough i think it's an adverse
effect to it because what really helped
put the roche i'm saying 1.0 is on the
ultra boost
is when kanye wore them when kanye wore
at concerts when he wore them
at powerhouse like back in like 2015 i
guess now five years ago
so like he helped elevate the ultra
boost to what it was at that point it
was like one of the hottest shoes in the
streets that
mark at that time and it's crazy because
even like later that year obviously the
three fees dropped
so like they were both so fly but it was
obviously like a levels to it you know
what i mean like it was like ultra boost
here 350's here
roshi's like way below underneath the
screen here so i
i christian i agree with you man but i
don't want to discount the real
hype of the roshi right this is a
sneaker that originally debuted
in 2012 for 70 dollars right
at that time that price point is
unfathomable you know i can take mom's
mom's take me to the store you know a
senior high school meech and i can get
two
three pairs that's the price of you know
what what one
ultra boost was and at the time you know
the roshi run was like really an
athlete's shoe you know
it was it was what uh now we have the
slides but you know at this at the time
athletes for rocking roshi runs before
and after games
for you seventy dollars man for real
beat that lebron lebron wore them
yeah i'm not gonna front i'm i'm here to
be swayed
because i've seen people wear them damn
yeezys
in the worst way possible i seen a dude
wear a suit
with with yeezys it's like fam okay i
know you're you're you're
the culture you you know you're you're
you're high fashion
[ __ ] out of here like what are you
wearing and the suit wasn't even tapered
so what what type of like he was wearing
like the the lebron
03 size boxy suit
that you just got off the rack because
you know you making millions so
you know forget forget a tailor i'm
trying to get paid i'm trying to shake
david stern hand
like that so yeah man i'm here to be
swayed because i
i totally agree if it didn't say yeezy
it would be
in marshalls right now and not as like a
hidden gem
i think a lot of actually probably had
to do obviously because the kanye height
we all know that
but those were legit like game-changer
shoes that were like hold up
like stripes over checks high vibes like
you know what i mean like
at that time that's what i was kind of
giving off so like i don't know i
don't think the roach has ever had that
effect like where the point i guess it
wasn't the competition at that time but
i think the [ __ ] had that effect on
the streetwear scene like that everybody
wore them for sure but but then it comes
it comes to me and it's like all right
we did have you know those
awesome original releases of the 350
right but now here we are
five years later four or five years
later and they're regurgitated so much
you know i've seen couple ways that look
five
six the same time and
if i'm looking back to the roshi run and
obviously you know the price point on
these on these users are still 200 250
the russian was seventy dollars man i
can get all my colors
and that but at least i had variety with
the yeezys i have i have sand
i have dust i have i have uh i have
coral
i have um all of these colors that are
all the same
they're making up colorways they're
trying to make it they're trying to give
it
some like mythology when in fact it's
just the roshi runs on steroids
right no i mean it's like we we talk
about
kanye and i don't want to i'm not trying
to [ __ ] on him but
the dude walks around and says he's mr
innovation
but literally the guy just put some
cheat like some like
prince on some roshi runs and said
i'm changing the game i mean he did but
is it because we're stupid
i mean i just yeah i just i want to make
sure that we know
that the roshi's walked so the yeezys
could run you know what i mean
when he was coming up with the concepts
for the uh
yeezy 350s he said that he wanted to
replace that shoe and he was talking
about that shoe he was talking about
the roshi run obviously we see a lot
of the inspiration there but i would
also like to see some innovation there
right and he we had it in the beginning
but now i feel like it's just too copy
paste for me man and
i feel like that's why i'm writing for
the roast rooms because at least there
was
at the time it was something new right
and
there's still chances for the roshiron
to come back and make a name for herself
you know
if the yeezys can do this nike really
wanted to put their money behind the
roshi run and make it
you know compete with the everyday shoe
i think they could have they could gain
that kind of momentum
yeah i mean let's throw an artist uh
collab with the roshi runs
the the game it completely changes
add an article put it on sneakers nobody
gets it but the bots
there's your hype mean we've already
seen so many celebs
rep the uh wrecked erosion run in the
past
you know and a lot of these guys are
nike guys now i can't name them on top
of my head but
i know cj you're real you're really
familiar with it top tier celebrities
drake lebron kanye himself
uh bieber not a fan but bieber
yeah i mean at that time it was a it
wasn't it was in a shoe that you clowned
it was like a staple like everyone had a
pair
it was like the the uh the high fashion
casual shoe cj you hit on a great point
there you said
everyone had a pair when kanye went into
adidas and started making 350s one of
his promises was
i would like everyone to own a pair of
yeezys
do you guys really think that he's
fulfilled that promise or actually made
easy that attainable for
the everyday person if he's on dropping
different versions giving more
individuals more chances and chances off
this similar silhouette like
he's doing that and like maybe the
innovation isn't always there from
version one version two version three
first of all i'm really upset at making
me like hold the easy crown right now
like i mean
i'm
yes other issues that kind of help the
innovation like the 350s are
the 380s are a spin off of the 350s
right like you have the wave runners
obviously you have the 750s you have
like some of the new avla v3s or like
all those 700s like all the different
innovative shoes off of like what he
originally did in 2015 the nmd r1
released right
the black blue and red pair for
originally 170
okay now nmds are about 140 and then the
ultra boost also released for about 180
yeah and also 350s i believe released
that year
so i want to know from you which of
these three do you think was the most
impactful on this sneaker game people
really love that ultra boost technology
like i remember just like
non-sneaker heads a few months after the
hype died down they're like i just got
these ultra boosts
you know it was like it was like a shoe
that it looked good and then when they
got it they're like oh yeah this is
legit like this has some function to it
like i have to give it to adidas at that
time
i really feel like it was the ultra
boost that was like oh we can wear
runners as a lifestyle shoe shifting
gear is here uh
a little bit guys i definitely want to
go into
uh some comments that kanye made the
other day he said he said i should be
able to wear jordan's especially as a
black man from chicago
do y'all agree because i definitely
agree listen i know
kanye you signed with the adidas your
name's on the dotted line it's in the
contract you can't wear other brands
but this is kanye west we're talking
about
a better deal it's not a better deal so
if your kanye west put in your deal that
you could wear whatever you want because
it doesn't matter what i wear on my feet
i'm going to sell for you
you're kanye west write up sign up
better he should know he's a rapper
why'd you leave nike if you wanted to i
mean can you blame him
leave i'm going to to help i'm a
multi-millionaire i don't
i don't i don't beli i don't blame him
at all and and
from a human perspective we should be
able to be free to whatever we
wear whatever we want from a business
perspective
it looks a little crazy imagine tim cook
having a uh having running windows i
don't even know what the what they
brought was it edge now
imagine jim cook running microsoft edge
on
on his laptop like you know and if he
does
we don't know about it i'm just saying
like
i think he should be able to but put it
in your deal aren't there like
um shoe deals that basketball players
sign where they say when i'm on the
court i have to wear this sneaker but
off the court i could wear whatever we
got to realize we're here we're talking
about sneakers the game is a game
because of
jordan's and like we love when brands
are self-aware and i almost think
it'd be a good look on adidas to be like
listen we're going to give the tiniest
shout out to jordans
for getting us here uh so you can wear
jordan especially since you're from
chicago
but also too like kanye is not the only
one i remember
stories growing up about how iverson i
mean we remember iris in the college
days
he he like he's the second most famous
person to make those concordes uh
look good to me with those georgetown
unis and then i remember when
harden signed with adidas yeah like
there were those stories coming out
that literally like he had signed the
deal with adidas but it didn't start for
another like two months and he was
wearing jordans
till the day the adidas contract started
like
they had to make the commercial that
adidas came and dropped off
all new adidas like a whole collection
they're like here's the
diesel collection please stop wearing
jordan's heart and so like
we all gotta admit like all these adidas
and reebok and whoever else is out there
wade all these people they definitely
have jordans in their collection they're
definitely wearing them when they're not
on camera
if connie was to also you know leave
take the easy line make him on his
own could we see it competing with
the nikes adidas puma
reebok what do you guys think it
probably would be smart for him to just
link up with another shoe brand for
distribution and and
you know that's where that's one of the
main uh reasons why i think uh big
bbb the triple triple b's triple b's
went down
like you don't need to you don't need to
um put place any
stronger burden on yourself with that
maybe he can go to
uh another what if he brings something
back like
british knights or something nuts like
that
and makes like a yeezy line of that and
just makes its own yeezy but it's like
yo we bring it back or
what if he goes to puma oh yeah we talk
about also like re-energizing a line
you know the biggest thing is is retro
wing stuff
how i i can't imagine kanye hasn't
thought man i want to retro my nike
easies like
those are still such like a sacred shoe
you know so like if he gets out of his
deal
any any sort of deal uh new deal that
allows him to
re-release those nikes in other color
ways like that is a whole
untapped potential right there with
retroing nike yeezys
cj he even said it himself that he would
i think he said he wouldn't be mad if
nike retro did his shoe
yeah he wants him he wants some he's a
fan of his own nike
dj what what jordans do you think hani
wants to wear
sixes jordan sixes yeah which ones
jordan sixes yeah this the infrareds
wow you used to wear i remember when he
wore those at the courtside once msg
with the leather pants i forgot about
that wow
i was thinking at first i was trying to
figure out what you want to wear off
whites because he mentioned like he
wants to wear his friend's shoes
so i'm trying to figure out is it like a
an off-white thing you know how
like when virgil and kanye finally met
up again an lv a runaway show like how
big that was
so i don't know if it's like that thing
or maybe some don c shoes i don't really
know yeah it's got
it's virgil and don c you're telling
he's got to be like they're all
on a group chat dropping pictures of
their shoes being like what do you think
of these like give me some feedback
but i feel yeah i mean kanye wants to
wear his friends creations you know